[Musica]
quando il bambino era bambino
camminava con le braccia ciondoloni
voleva che il bruscello fosse un fiume
il fiume un torrente e questa
pozzanghera il mare quando il bambino
era bambino non sapeva di essere un
bambino per lui tutto aveva un'anima e
tutte le anime erano un tutt'uno
quando il bambino era bambino non aveva
opinioni sul nulla non aveva abitudini
sedeva spesso con le gambe incrociate e
di colpo si metteva a correre
aveva un vortice tra i capelli e non
faceva facce da fotografo quando il
bambino era bambino era l'epoca di
queste domande perché io sono io perché
non sei tu
perché io sono qui perché non sono lì
quando comincia il tempo e dove finisce
lo spazio la vita sotto il sole
e forse solo un sogno non è solo
l'apparenza di un mondo davanti al mondo
quello che vedo che sento che ho duro
c'è veramente il male è gente veramente
cattiva come può essere che io che sono
io non c'ero prima di diventare e che
una volta io che sono io non sarò più
quello che sono
quando il bambino era bambina si
strozzava con gli spinaci i piselli con
il riso al latte e con il cavolfiore
bollito e oggi mangia tutto questo e non
solo per necessità
una volta si svegliano letto sconosciuto
e adesso questo gli succede sempre molte
persone e gli sembravano belle e adesso
questo gli succede solo in qualche raro
caso di fortuna si immaginava
chiaramente il paradiso e oggi riesce
appena a sospettarlo non riusciva a
immaginarsi il nulla e oggi 3 ma alla
sua idea quando il bambino era bambino
giocava con entusiasmo e oggi è tutto
immerso nella cosa come allora soltanto
quando questa cosa è il suo lavoro
quando il bambino era bambino per
nutrirsi gli bastavano pane e mela ed è
ancora così
quando il bambino era bambino le bacche
gli cadevano in mano come solo le bacche
sanno cadere ed è ancora così le noci
fresche iras pavano la lingua ed è
ancora così a ogni monte sentiva
nostalgia per una montagna ancora più
alta e in ogni città sentiva nostalgia
per una città ancora più grande ed è
ancora così sulla cima dell'albero
prendeva le ciliegie tutte off o rico
con me ancora oggi aveva timore davanti
a ogni estraneo e continua ad averlo
aspettava la prima neve e continua
ad aspettarla
quando il bambino era bambino lanciava
contro l'albero un bastone come fosse
una lancia che continua ancora a vibrare
[Musica]
e luce
o meglio
passo e chiudo
[Musica]
brava e la fragranza
mi cade tra
[Musica]
ci va giù
con la guida
[Musica]
lo show
viber
squadra per sempre
[Musica]
allora i voti
ma è tanto la vita
[Musica]